this is a production of cornell
university
thank you gillian for the honor to
introduce maureen hansen who's up excuse
me a perfect choice to give the sips
plenary lecture today
maureen who is a liberty
hi bailey professor here at cornell
has joint appointments in the department
of molecular biology and genetics and in
plant biology so
she's probably well known to many of the
people here but i thought i'd provide a
few background details of her stellar
career
maureen has been interested in plant
biology for a long time beginning with
majoring in plant biology as an
undergraduate at duke continuing with
her graduate work at harvard with larry
bogorad on
chloroplasts and their ribosomes and
then her postdoctoral work with fred
osibel also at harvard
she then took a faculty position at the
university of virginia before moving to
cornell as an associate professor in
1985.
maureen's lab has made a dazzling set of
important contributions to our
understanding of biology
in general and plant biology in
particular
her work is um notable for
for doing for connecting very
high level
fundamental biology
with potential applications in literally
in the field
one of her lab's earliest contributions
was on the basis for cytoplasmic male
sterility in plants
using petunias as a model system
maureen's lab showed that the causative
agent was a gene fusion expressed in
mitochondria
and then went on to identify a nuclear
gene that restored fertility the first
member of the ppr
group of proteins that are now common
fertility restorer genes in cases of cms
so that was beautiful
but in a completely different area
maureen's gfp labeling in her lab
revealed that there were tubules that
connect plastids like chloroplasts
um that she called stromules and allow
the transit of proteins and other
molecules between chloroplasts and also
play a role in plant disease
and that was beautiful too
but in a completely different area at
the same time she and her lab also
elucidated mechanisms
by which plasmids edit the sequences of
their mrnas
changing about 600 cytosines in
mitochondria and about 30 or 40 in
chloroplasts
to
uracils which of course changes the
protein
nature that's that's coded for that
so she worked on this and also
identified the many of the components of
the editosome complex that makes these
changes and that interestingly include
ppr proteins like the
fertility restorer that she had
previously identified
that was nice too
but in a completely different fourth
area
she works on rubisco and um and that
will be the subject of her talk today so
you'll hear about that in a moment
so i just have a couple of more things
to say
maureen has with her about 25 grad
students and about 25 post docs
published over 200 papers many in top
journals
her work is incredibly highly regarded
in many many fields and she has received
a lot of awards and recognition for her
work just a few or that
she's a fellow of the triple a s she's
received awards from suny from cows from
the american society for plant biology
and last year was elected a week apart
to the national academy of sciences and
the american academy of arts and
sciences
on top of all this maureen has played
major administrative roles in her
discipline
as an editor as a conference chair on
grants panels etc and in fostering plant
biology at cornell
including 13 years
directing the cornell plant science
center and its training grants and
innovative programs so
she's really really incredibly amazing
that was plant marine
in addition to all of this work on
plants
maureen has an equally important equally
big and equally impactful research
initiative
on something completely unrelated to
plants
specifically the etiology
of myalgic
encephalitis which is also known as
chronic fatigue syndrome
in studies with physicians physical
therapists population geneticists and
others
she has identified metabolic phenotypes
in mecfs patients
including in their mitochondria in their
plasma proteins in their immune system
and differences in their microbiome
these are human patients here
her work has shown that me cfs is a
metabolic disease not a psychological
one critically important in these times
and she has her work is revealing ways
to diagnose or alleviate this disease
she also has a great deal of
communication with the public about it
some of the work that i
mentioned on this comes from a 9.4
million dollar
funded collaborative center that she
heads here
to investigate the pathophysiology of
mecfs
so
as you can hear maureen has touched
incredibly well many many many different
field plants and not plants and it's
really an honor for her for us to hear
her
talk about on how to improve
photosynthetic carbon assimilation in
plants
introduction is going to be a hard act
to follow
but it's also my first seminar in person
since uh january 2020 when i was in san
diego
for the plant and animal genome meeting
and it's it's really interesting to see
all these non-smiling faces wearing
masks out there
so
uh okay so i guess i better get started
and isn't it nice that that it actually
looks like this normally when i show
this photo it doesn't look like that in
ithaca
so i want to do a brief reminder about
c3 carbon fixation
before i start
this is of course well known to many
people in the room but let me just
remind you that rubisco is the enzyme
that's responsible for combining rubp
and co2 to create two three carbon
molecules that then are utilized in the
calvin cycle resulting in all those nice
products that we get in plants
sugar starch amino acids and fatty acids
but rubisco can react with oxygen
instead of co2 and when that happens we
have photorespiration
in which one toxic two carbon molecule
and one three carbon molecule are
produced
then resulting in the release of co2
loss of energy and fixed carbon and
production of ammonia
so rubisco is an issue it limits
photosynthetic efficiency in two
different ways
not only by photorespiration but also it
has a very slow catalytic rate only
three molecules co2 fixed per second in
a typical plant a
flowering plant and then also as a
result of this slow turnover rate
we have 25 to 50 percent of the total
leaf-soluble protein
is actually rubisco and that uses up 25
of the leaf nitrogen so there is a big
issue with rubisco and it's a target for
improvement
so we're taking two strategies to
enhance rubisco efficiency and i'm going
to give my talk in two parts the first
part is
an effort to create a new plant
subcompartment to increase the
concentration of co2 near rubisco and
that's the first topic i will go over
so some photosynthetic organisms have
involved ways to deal with this problem
of rubisco
and these are shown here there's the c4
pathway the cam pathway the paranoid and
the carboxysome and all of these put
more co2 in the vicinity of rubisco to
assist with this problem of
photorespiration and also
increase the
efficiency
so we actually decided to focus on the
carboxysome as a strategy
to
improve uh photosynthetic carbon
simulation
we had have had a grant
from a special program at nsf an nsf
bbsrc program
for synthesis of these microcompartments
and this is a collaboration with
lancaster university
uh with elizabeth karma silva and martin
kerry the pis and doug orr the senior
postdoc
and with the university of glasgow with
mike blatt
at cornell
this work has been done by miyatlin
vishal chaudhary and kevin hines who is
a bmcb student who has now graduated and
moved to northeastern and we had a 2018
reu student
and vishal and miata are here
and
available to answer questions which is
uh always helpful
so
cyanobacteria avoid photorespiration
with this co2 concentrating
microcompartment the carbonic the
carboxy stone in this the rubisco is
enclosed within this compartment
along with carbonic anhydrase
so that
carbonic anhydra
bicarbonate enters can is converted to
co2 and then the rubisco has an enriched
co2 atmosphere
in order to carry out its
carbon fixation this is what these
carboxysomes actually look like
in in the cyanobacterium
so the question then is can we take this
cyanobacterial carbon concentrate
trading mechanism and put it into plants
so here is the diagram in in the
cyanobacteria
you see that bicarbonate is pumped in
into this uh into this compartment the
idea is to transfer the carboxysome
structure into
into a chloroplast and this is not
uh entirely accurate because you need
more than one carboxylam you need you
need hundreds of carboxy stones in there
and you'd need your pump
uh and in order to get all of this to
work
the modeling was done by a
former collaborator of our steve long's
group
and that showed that if you could
actually achieve this the potential
increase in yield would be as much as 60
percent
now we've published a number of papers
about producing the structure of the
carboxy sum
and i'm not going to describe these here
since they're all published
but this work is uh being continued by
our collaborators in lancaster
uh and and actually our current grant
ends in december and they will continue
that work and we're going to be doing
something else that i will related that
i will tell you about
so one issue is that the carbonic
anhydrase in the chloroblast
must be confined to the carboxy cell
it's not confined right now because
there is carbonic anhydrase in naturally
in the chloroplast of plants
but it was shown by a group some years
ago that if you put carbonic anhydrase
into the cytoplasm of cyanobacteria
that prevents the carboxysome from
working
because the problem is the co2 is then
released in the cytoplasm instead of
within the carboxy cell
so we potentially would have the same
problem in the plant if we were to put a
carboxysum in there
so clearly we need to remove
the chloroplast stromocarbonic anhydrase
in order to have the carboxy sum to work
so the question though is what happens
if all the carbonic anhydrase is removed
from the chloroplast stroma is this
going to do something bad to the plant
this hasn't been done to in the past but
when we started to remove all of the
carbonic anhydrase from the chloroplast
now the role of carbonic anhydrase and
c4 photosynthesis is understood but
we're working on c3 photosynthetic
plants
in c4 photosynthesis the uh the carbonic
anhydrase is responsible for for uh
conversion between co2 and bicarbonate
which is then used to make oxaloacetate
and then malate is uh sent in is
converted from that and sent in to the
bundle sheath to carry out c4
photosynthesis so we understand why
there's carbonic anhydrase
in the chloroplasts of
c4 plants but we don't really know why
it's present in c3 plants we don't know
what the role of carbonic anhydrase and
photosynthesis would be but it's always
been thought that it had a role in c3
photosynthesis
in 1994 dean price's lab removed most of
the chloroplast carbonic anhydrase using
antisense technology
they got down to two percent of the
normal chloroplast carbonic anhydrase
activity in some of their plants their
antisense plants which was the
state-of-the-art technology at the time
they didn't see any effect on a
carbon assimilation or leaf dry weight
or chlorophyll
the problem with this study is that
carbonic anhydrase is one of the most
efficient enzymes
and even just two percent of carbonic
anhydrase could have a very important
effect
on the plant so you really need to
remove all of it if you're going to
understand its effect when you drink a
soda by the way
and you get those bubbles released in
your mouth that's your that's your
saliva carbonic anhydrase releasing the
co2 and it happens almost instantly as
you just take one drink and and have the
co2 released
so
uh kevin labeled uh uh the
uh uh
the uh chloroplast punitive chloroplast
carbonic anhydrases with uh
with yfp to verify
uh that these indeed were chloroplast
carbonic anhydrases and you can see
these
these bodies here are chloroplasts
and you can see these are those those
tubules that mariana mentioned in the
introduction here
that we uh
rediscovered in 1997
and it was my pleasure to have patricia
conklin who is a former ggd student
who's now a suny full professor suny
cortland a full professor come and do a
sabbatical with me and actually work on
these stromels
and uh we have a recent article if
you're interested in these uh
describing the current state of what we
know about stromiel but that's an aside
let me get back to carbonic anhydrase so
there are zinc binding residues in
carbonic anhydrase that are known to be
essential for the enzymatic activity
and so kevin hines sent out to use
crispr cas9 to knock out
the carbonic anhydrase genes
in plant in
tobacco that
are our tar are make proteins that are
targeted to the chloroplast
so he designed uh he designed constructs
that had two targets with the idea that
you would get a nice deletion and here's
an example of such a deletion that was
created
by uh by crispr cast nine however this
is the exception because this actually
did not work very well and instead
we actually got mainly mutants that had
small deletions or point mutations
nevertheless we were able to mutagenize
the two chloroplast carbonic anhydrase
genes
uh
with uh by doing this
these uh single mutants have completely
normal morphology so this happens to be
ca1
knocked out and this is ca5 and the
morphology is is uh as far as you can
see
it looks just like a regular uh
you know tobacco plant
however the double mutant that knocks
out both of them is abnormal even on
sucrose median so it looks like this
it's barely
getting along
in sucrose medium but if you transfer it
to high co2
and this is the maximum co2 that we can
actually put in our growth chambers over
in wildhaul
because any more than that osha says you
might stick your head in and get
asphyxiated so so this is what we this
is what we can give them and this um
this is this normalization is likely
because there's some spontaneous
conversion
of bicarbonate and co2 that high co2
drives the reaction
uh
to give you enough bicarbonate
and if you transfer that plant back into
uh low co2 you then uh end up with uh
plants looking very abnormal again but
they do survive because they're being
fed by these leaves here that that were
formed during the
uh during the high co2
so by
kevin then went on to assay
uh carbonic anhydrase activity and he
was having trouble getting a source of
uh carbonated water so i had to bring in
my
sodastream
which is what he used to to make the
carbon to the carbonated water to do the
assay and you can see that when you
knock out ca1 there's very little ca
activity left
ca5 there's not a whole lot of effect of
that because ca5 is obviously not one of
the more important
proteins
but if you knock both of them out then
there's very little ca
activity so we then
went to our colleague tom owen so i
don't see here although maybe he is
online
because he was a great help in fact
essential for this study because
he actually did these experiments uh
with kevin to look at ps2 efficiency
to find out whether there is actually
any impairment in photosynthesis
and
given tom's
expertise he assured us that these
graphs showing really no difference
between the single mutant the double
mutant and wild type
really reveals that there's no effect on
photosynthesis
however unfortunately some reviewers
didn't agree that tom knew what he was
doing and instead said oh no you have to
do carbon assimilation experiments as
well
and for that we're grateful that
michelle got involved in this project
and performed these experiments
showing that even at low uh oxygen where
there's very little photo photo
respiration
or atmospheric levels of oxygen there's
you really cannot distinguish the double
mutant from the wild type and so this
again is further evidence that there's
really no effect on
uh there's no effect on uh
photosynthesis of removing
the uh the carbonic anhydrase
so this is uh was breaking a paradigm so
it took us quite a while to get this
published in fact almost two years to
get this published because because it
wasn't believed but now fortunately uh
it is out and and you can read it in
pnas
so why do chloroplasts need stromal
localized uh
carbonic anhydrase for this normal leaf
development it turns out that
bicarbonate's a substrate for
biosynthetic pathways and chloroplasts
and these are just two of those
biosynthetic pathways there's about a
half a dozen biosynthetic pathways that
need bicarbonate so if you don't if you
don't uh have bicarbonate present there
and these pathways are are not going to
function properly
in fact this has con this has
consequences that you can see easily
even when with those anti-sense plants
it was shown back in 2002
that the uh
uh that the incorporation of acetate
into chloroplast lipids was reduced so
lipid synthesis in the chloroplast was
reduced even in the plants that had uh
two percent and were totally normal
looking our plants that are very unhappy
looking uh definitely have a disturbed
lipid profile uh in in double mutant
leaves as acid
over in the brc here
and so so this is evidence of
biochemical disruption as the as a
result of the absence of bicarbonate
the phenotype of the plant is also
uh very abnormal and this isn't what
tobacco's supposed to look like let
drosophila geneticists know that this
isn't isn't what tobacco reproduction
looks like normally this is these buds
have there have been buds that have
fallen off of these uh of this tobacco
uh in in ambient co2 once in a while a
bud will make it and make some seeds but
most of them fall off
and the seeds that develop
in ambient co2
here are also sort of hollowed out and
very abnormal you could imagine that
flippant synthesis is impaired that that
this would this would uh result in an
abnormal seed
so
uh so what about complementation uh we
did complement this using the 35s
promoter complement it with ca1 and the
complementation shows that you get
complete normalization of the phenotype
when you complement with the normal
carbonic anhydrase protein however
uh if you make a ca protein with the
gene
that lacks the chloroplast transit
sequence in other words this carbonic
anhydrase is synthesized but it's
remaining in the in the cytoplasm it's
not going into the chloroplast
then you get no complementation
and as a further
demonstration that you need enzymatic
activity for this normalization uh kevin
made a mutant protein mutated in that
zinc
site and put that into the plant and
again there is no complementation
uh when
there's a mutation in the active site
now one problem about using a plant that
doesn't have
ca1 in it is that it's actually known to
do something else it's actually a
salicylic
acid binding protein
required for the hypersensitive response
so uh i think most people here know that
a hypersensitive response defends
against virus
uh as
this program cell death prevents the
spread of virus and so if you had a
plant lacking bca1 you'd expect it to be
sensitive to tobacco mosaic virus and
potentially other viruses
but with dense classics help kevin did
another experiment and that was to see
if he could express the inactivated vca1
and get the hypersensitive response the
answer is yes so here's a wild-type leaf
with a hypersensitive response lesion
bca1 has no such lesion after being
inoculated with tmv nor does bca1
uh
the double mutants
and the bca5 still does have a
hypersensitive response because it
still has vca1 present but this here's a
lesion made
uh uh in this plant that has the uh
zinc uh binding region uh deleted uh and
so we can still get the hypersensitive
response by putting in a bca1 that has
no carbonic anhydrase activity but is
still able to function in the salicylic
acid signaling pathway and cause a
hypersensitive response
so the question then is will this
abnormal plant development ambient co2
when uh when ca is removed prevent the
production of plants with engineered
carboxysomes
uh
this back to this diagram we think that
this is actually not going to be a
problem because we need to do something
else to make this car this carbon
concentrating mechanism work and that is
to put a pump
on the chloroplast envelope just like
it's on the cyanobacterial
uh
membrane in order to get uh the
bicarbonate pumped in
thereby this bicarbonate could be used
not only in the
carboxy
but also for those biosynthetic pathways
so our current project now we've been
able to be refunded by nsf and that's to
introduce bicarbonate transporters from
microbes onto the chloroplast membrane
and that's a project that's going to be
started in january
being carried out by vishal chaudhry and
we
as as something that we we have it
benefits this is we actually now have a
bio bicarbonate requiring mutants that's
what those double mutants is if we
succeed in putting this pump on then
we're hoping we will be able to get a
normalization of the plant
phenotype
so uh this is
this is the summary of part one
and um
uh
i'll go over this really quickly but
i've shown you that tobacco uh lacking
stromal carbonic anhydrase has no
abnormal growth and development
but that
doesn't impair photosynthesis
uh if if we express uh the ca and the
cytoplasm or inactivate it we don't get
the normal phenotype and we believe that
uh like the ca's role is to supply
bicarbonate to enzymes needed for
biosynthetic processes
and we can restore the hypersensitive
response with an enzymatically inactive
ca1
and we think that the removal of this
thermal ca should be feasible if
bicarbonate pumps are installed on the
chloroplast envelope
i now would like to move on to the
second project which is to mutagenize
rubisco to have higher turnover rate
let me just again remind people although
many of you know this that vascular
plant rubisco is comprised of subunits
encoded by both the chloroplast nuclear
genome
the small subunit by the nuclear genome
and the eight large subunits by a single
gene that's present in the chloroplast
genome
we can use chloroplast
transformation to replace the plant rbcl
by homologous recombination
and this
procedure was worked out many years ago
in palmylgus lab
the transformation vectors one uses
typically carry a spectinomous myosin
resistance marker
and this just shows the procedure that
you need to carry out
you do you do bombardment of your little
seedlings
you you regenerate resistant uh
antibiotic resistant ones
but you haven't transformed all of the
chloroplast genome so you have to do
another round of selection
and then you have to check whether
they're homoplasmic in other words so
that you completely replaced all of the
mu and the wild-type genomes and if you
have you can go to rooting and make a
plan
so you need at least three to four
months to do this procedure maybe six
months if you're unlucky
so but we can do this so how how do we
alter rubisco though for this improved
enzymatic properties that we would like
so one possibility would be to identify
amino acids or alter the c3 to c4
transition since c4 rubisco is faster
uh
and
and you know potentially couldn't
result in improved rubisco
so
10 homoplasmic rbcl mutants were
actually produced
and
they look fairly normal
and there was no effect on rubisco
abundance by making these mutations now
the mutations that were put in were
either one amino acid change or maybe
two amino acid changes
however these uh
mutations
uh while they affected uh they uh
affected enzyme kinetics they didn't
affect them in the right direction they
actually made the rubisco worse you can
see here
that this is two different types of wild
type it's between 2.4 and 2.6 and in
every case the uh kinetics are actually
uh are actually worse in the mutant
rubisco
um
so
so this is clearly not the greatest
strategy to uh to try to improve rubisco
and the other problem with this strategy
is that take so
if you wanted to test say a hundred
different rubiscos imagine the amount of
work you'd have to do to put this into a
plan well fortunately in 2017
there was a breakthrough in in
manajit higher heartless lab in which
she was for the first time able to
assemble
plant rubisco and e coli using five
chloroplast chaperones
and when she did this i put in a rabbit
she was able to get arabidopsis
uh rubisco synthesized pretty well here
pretty good amount of uh arabidopsis
rubisco assembled
and by adding uh one of the tobacco
chaperones she was able to get a little
bit of
tobacco rubisco assembled
this however would not be enough for our
purposes we wanted to use this system to
express mutant rubiscos and look at
their kinetics
so miat lin
set out to improve this system and he
converted the three plasmids into two
and rearranged things and i'm not going
to go into this
it's now published
and it's probably not of much interest
but the bottom line is that he was able
to get a very good yield of assembled
rubisco by making these alterations in
the chaperones used in the promoters etc
so he went on to study
uh the seven unique small subunits that
are encoded by the tobacco genome now
tobacco is is uh an allotropide so
actually they're quite a number of um
small subunits either from the parental
line sylvesterous designated s
or temento sephoramis designated as t
some of these are pseudogenes s3 looks
like a pseudogene
this is the expression level in
young leaf or mature leaf
according to
database data and you can see that there
are a number of well-expressed uh
rubisco subunits at the rna level
these seven uh
were then further studied now notice
that there's a trichome rabisco you
wouldn't really expect there to be a
rubisco in trichomes but was discovered
a few years ago that there's a trichome
rubisco that has a small subunit that's
very different than the leaf subunits
you see all these changes the red
changes are different from leaf
rubisco so what it's doing we don't
really know
but
experiments with this trichome rubisco
indicates it's it has a lower affinity
for co2 and a faster catalytic rate
so the experiment that we wanted to do
was to to find out
uh
you know what
the properties of this the enzymes
produced in e coli did they really mimic
the wild type e coli or not the wild
type rubisco in plants or not so in a
plant because there are multiple genes
and multiple proteins
around there's multiple four proteins
are likely to actually exist where you
have
multiple small subunits assembled into
your rubisco enzyme
but in e coli you're only if you only
express one of those small subunits
you're getting a very uniform enzyme
you're getting that single large subunit
along with your single small small
subunit that you choose
so we can test the the
enzyme efficiency with these different
uh
small subunits we can also find out if
the unusual trichome rubisco kinetics is
also reproduced in e coli
well this is the bottom line
it turns out indeed that the e coli
system's pretty good
the case the uh
the kc and the k-cat are fairly similar
to the native enzyme so there's a little
it's a lo there's a little bit lower
affinity
for co2 uh in the e coli system but it's
not bad and there's and it looks like
the trichome rubisco kinetics is
reproduced so again the k-cat is
actually quite similar for most
of these uh
subunits when you express it in
in e coli so this is good enough for us
to go on and use
to express mutant enzymes
in plants
in e coli and then find out what their
kinetics are
but the question is how do we decide to
make the mutations
uh in rubisco uh given that just look
you know mutating one or two didn't do
much good
so another possibility
would be
uh to use information from ancient
history
and um
uh almost to the time of the dinosaurs
uh and i put this light here so i could
have a chance to get a quick drink of
water so you can enjoy the joke
i looked up and it turns out that
dinosaurs actually have brains about the
size of a lime not a walnut
anyway so the idea is
that rubisco enzymes and c3 plants
have evolved at a much lower
co2 than is currently
out there in the atmosphere
so 408 parts per million is what was the
latest measurement
uh uh in hawaii so
um
so we're we're definitely higher than uh
uh co2 has been for quite a while
in fact if you look here this is when
the dinosaurs
uh became extinct there was a period of
time here when there was much higher co2
uh
than we have now
uh
but uh but unfortunately we're heading
that way
and so this might be a source of
information the ancestral enzymes that
exist there might be a source of
information for
valuable rubisco enzymes
so the new strategy is to predict
rubisco enzymes that existed 20 to 30
million years ago in solanaceae and
tobacco is a member of the solanaceae
family these are just some
other ver other
members of the family
i'd like to now give credit to miat lin
yeah i'd like to take credit for this
idea but it wasn't mine it was actually
miata's idea
uh he suggested to me and i immediately
thought this is a great idea we have to
go do this
this opinion of mine however is is uh my
only contribution to the idea is that i
thought it was good
unlike several sets of grant proposal
reviewers
who thought it was not such a good idea
and it's always a pleasure to prove
grant proposal reviewer is wrong
so miat has spearheaded this project
with only the help of a rotation student
who spent a brief period in the lab
and in our night 2019 are you student
all the other work that i'm going to
present was done by beyond himself
so here's the predicted evolutionary
timeline within solanaceae
if you want to go back
about 30 million years this is where you
can this gives you an idea of the nodes
where you can go back and find those and
send ancestral enzymes
so the problem about this though is that
there were too few rubisco small
subunits to reliably predict the
ancestral sequences
you know there were only five genera
that there were sequences available
and then so in the ncbi database this is
all that was there however there are a
lot of data in the um
rna-seq databases that could be mined
and this is what miat did
he mined these databases i'm not going
to go through this there's not time but
the bottom line is by doing this he was
able to get some additional large
subunits
and a large number of additional small
subunits so he's now got 17 genera
instead of five represented
here and and uh he's got some additional
large subunits as well
doing this he was able to
produce
a phylogenetic tree and predict a large
number of ancestral enzymes and in the
subsequent slides you're going to see
these different nodes represented by
different colors so we've got orange
red
uh
brown and green
and what miat did which during the
pandemic
was to express 98 of these predicted
viscoenzymes
express them in e coli and then
characterize them by this rapid
screening method
so the blue line is the bar above which
the enzymes are showing some indication
of being superior
to
the
wild-type enzyme when it's expressed in
e coli so these enzymes here are good
candidates for further study and in fact
miat then selected 38 for full kinetic
curves
uh uh which is of course a lot more work
than this initial screen
in order to see if they also were
superior
and indeed it turned out that this assay
of ancestral enzymes revealed a number
of them that have superior properties in
comparison to present day rubisco
so for example here
this hat these enzymes have a higher
catalytic efficiency and also a higher
turnover rate so these are really uh
interesting candidates to
study more and these could never have
been predicted just by looking at this
structure because these have multiple
10 or so amino acid changes
so to summarize part two we can express
plant rubisco and e coli
we we could
study in these the endogenous small
subunits
uh miatas obtain many more sequences of
the large and small subunits can use
that to construct a phylogenetic tree
expressed 98 of
these enzymes in e coli and some of
these definitely have improved catalytic
efficiency
so what's our next step here
my last slide i'm going to say our next
step is to replace the endogenous
rubisco with ancestral rubisco through
chloroplast transformation and that's
the project that will be we'll be doing
this this coming year thank you
okay we have two minutes before 1 10. i
don't know if we're being thrown out
there then or uh
no
questions for maureen um zoom audience
in person audience
hinder the
cat boxes on formation
i couldn't hear that how does the
carbonic anhydrase okay uh prevents the
formation of
catabols
how does the how does the carbonic
anhydrase how does the carbonic
anhydrase
in the in this in the chloroplast why
would that prevent formation
of it doesn't prevent formation of the
carboxy cells it prevents the mechanism
from working
so in the cyanobacteria when they put
carbonic anhydrase in the cytoplasm
which is of course the equivalent of the
stroma
the problem was that the co2 was
released in the cytoplasm it wasn't
released inside the carboxy zone so you
need to have the bicarbonate sitting
around in the cytoplasm or the stroma
and then being transported by a pump
into the carboxy sum where then the
carbonic anhydrase inside the carbonic
inside the carboxy sum will release the
co2 for utilization by ribisco
so that's why you have to get rid of it
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu